do I have a favorite Seth Rogen movie I
mean I wrote a lot of the movies that I
made so it's itself it's an egocentric
or questions task I have to pick one
that I didn't write or direct by it's
just to make myself not look like an
[ __ ] the 40 cows that my characters
named cow C al cow I play a guy who's a
novelist who works a struggling novelist
who works in a like a Best Buy it's
called smart tech in the movie yeah I
covered myself in fake tattoos for that
it's cuz I like went to a Best Buy I
don't do a ton of research generally
speaking but I went to a Best Buy to
kind of see well me if there was anyone
I could base my character on and a lot
of guys there were like tatted the [ __ ]
up and I was like oh that's a funny
thing for like just in general like to
be buying a like a stereo from a guy
with like really scary tattoos all over
him had a lot of good band shirts I
don't I work a lot from the outside in
as you can see tattoos t-shirts these
are the things I base my characters but
yeah we're just I had a liquid source
t-shirt in that movie and I think I wear
a Nirvana I think I nevermind t-shirt
and maybe a Sonic Youth t-shirt as well
there was a lot of good t-shirt work in
that film so a my finest t-shirt work
that was your first like major motion
picture that you were in right it was I
had a small partners really Donnie Darko
but an anchorman was maybe before that
but yeah that was my forgiver Jim was
for sure my first role that was like
that like you would go to the movie and
like remember who the [ __ ] I was
basically it was great work it was Steve
Carell I really have the set like you
got the sense he was uncomfortable with
how dirty the movie was and it's funny
because like if you look at his career
beyond that film he never made another
movie like that in any way shape or form
like he really he changed direction like
that movie is like kind of an anomaly
sorry I'm late man oh no problem
oh man
I had a weekend yeah we went to Tijuana
Mexico you know and we thought it'd be
fun you know to go to the show
everyone's you got to check out one of
these shows and you know it's it's a
woman [ __ ] a horse we get there and
you know we think it's gonna be awesome
and it is not as cool as it sounds like
it would be man it is it's kind of gross
yeah
you think a woman [ __ ] a horse and
you get there and it's a woman [ __ ] a
horse yeah it was really giving it to
her and you know what to be honest I
felt bad for we all just felt bad for
kind of feel bad for the horse wow
that's something it was funny cuz like
it kind of reflected the dynamic in the
movie where like we were this like
filthy force in the life of this guy
who's a kind of pristine there's a scene
where Steve Carell gets his chest waxed
and and we waxed him for real hi are you
this is your first time getting body
walks yes yes it is
take off your shirt okay we had to just
stand there and watch it and it was
pretty [ __ ] up and he started bleeding
so ready yeah no no that's okay that's
two another
that one little patch looks sexy though
okay yeah it looks really good I
remember that was like a Misha I that
was like I we get I was a co-producer on
the movie so I would get writing
assignments and I remember one of my
assignment was to make things for him to
scream as he was getting waxed so he
didn't have to think of it I was
supposed to be making like a dirty list
and a clean list I remember I was the
dirty list was easy and the clean list
was hard and I remember I couldn't think
of anything at American Idol was on and
it was the year Kelly Clarkson was on
and I wrote Kelly Clarkson Kelly
Clarkson I wrote it as just
fill the page the JED wouldn't yell at
me but it turned into a lie that people
still remember I remember there was a
lot of discussion of like how do we show
the joy he has after losing his
virginity I remember Carell was like I
should just sing Age of Aquarius and
that's very funny
[Music]
there's a part where it's me and Jonah
and Mindy Kaling actually like dancing
together
Jonah got heatstroke that day for real
yeah it was [ __ ] up because he's
wearing like a poncho and a hat like a
winter hat and it was like a hundred and
fifteen degrees and we were in like
Temecula or some [ __ ] Superman he and
Evan Goldberg my friend and partner to
this day started riding super bad when
we were in high school we were in eighth
grade basically and it was incorporating
a lot of our like real-life high school
stories and originally I mean the
characters names are Seth and Evan after
me and Evan and originally I was gonna
play Seth and we would hire another
actor to play Evan who but it basically
took us so long to get the movie made
that I like aged out of the role
essentially and like we were like 24 by
the time we were making the movie and I
could not play 18 year old convincingly
anymore so I played this cop that was in
the mood I was always in the script and
III much more convincingly played like a
guy in his late 20s who was a really
irresponsible cop than a guy who was in
his late teens it was about to enter
college and so Jonah Hill played the
role I was originally gonna play to much
better effect than I ever could have
played it and Michael Cera played Evan
and it's funny because Michael Cera is
really not like the actual evidence but
he's much but he was perfect and I he
was he's just a genius and he really in
the script it was kind of like a
straight man and a funny guy but he made
the straight man just as funny as the
funny guy which was like something that
I've really grown to marvel at over the
years we found joy because we he's
actually originally a 40 year old virgin
and that was a scene I had written give
you some money
shoes and you know I know it seems so
strange yes I just rather buy them from
you straight up yeah I know I wish it
could be that easy but I wished you but
you're making it extremely difficult for
me I'm just trying to get these shoes
back to my house I can wear them
she works in this sell your stuff on
eBay store which was a thing at the time
which makes no [ __ ] sense and I
remember I was like rewriting the scene
with judge and I had this idea where
this guy comes in and tries to buy these
boots it just doesn't [ __ ] get it and
then I was in a movie theater seeing the
life aquatic and I felt a tap in my
shoulder and it was Jonah and he was
like you don't know me but I'm
auditioning for this role in a movie
that you're a producer on next week and
I he explained the rules like oh that's
so funny I wrote that role a few weeks
ago that's great and he came in and he
was like brilliant it was like one of
these like moments or you're just like
oh this guy's like [ __ ] leagues
funnier than most people you encounter
when we were making knocked up we
literally were like Jonah like he's he's
just brilliant and then he kept him
trying to convince us to put him in
Superbad and we were just like no like
you're too old and we thought he was too
old and then we I remember literally one
day we like had him come to like into my
trailer during knocked up and like
filmed him on like a camcorder I could
be allergic to poison juice I don't know
I've never tried it and you haven't but
the [ __ ] droughts over the flood
gates are opening we need to build a dam
to stop the [ __ ] juice from overflowing
onto us right
that's graphic and it was just so funny
Marilla God we were wrong like he can
totally do this very well and then and
then we so I was in this movie called
you me and Dupree which is like not a
fantastic movie it was actually directed
by the Russo brothers though who went on
to direct all the Avengers films and
become by far the most successful
filmmakers of all time but my friend did
the movie was Bill Hader who it was his
first season on set live like he had
been in a few episodes when we were
filming it and he was so funny and I
love remember meeting him and after her
days being like we were already going to
be making super bad and we were like you
should be in the movie there's a scene
where they're like the youngest guys
like a party full of older guys who
start doing coke who's that guy hi that
happened to me and Evan I was I did
stand-up comedy as a kid so I would hang
out with the Stan of comics sometimes
when I was like 16 and one time we went
to a party at one of their houses and
they all started doing coke and we wound
up in a room with these guys who were
very threatening towards us it was a lot
like the scene in the movie brother came
all the way from Scottsdale Arizona to
be here tonight and you're not gonna
sing for him [ __ ] [ __ ] think
you're a [ __ ] singer you sing and you
seem good sing it again like a bird no I
know I just I want to you want to lie to
cocaine no way man yeah the period blood
also happened we were at a high school
dance and we were in the locker room
afterwards and it it essentially played
out almost exactly like how it does in
the movie dude is that blood are you
bleeding
cutter anything won't I be bleeding
[ __ ] blood man you dancing with some
chick in there
yeah so yeah we were in the locker room
when we saw this watching the guys mans
me we're all kind of like trying to
figure out what it was and we were you
drinking wine like what like and then we
noticed like another group of guys in
the other corner of the walking locker
room having the exact same conversation
like looking at this watch on their
pants mean like what is it like did a
pan explode in my pocket like what
happened and then because there was - we
like peas - we saw each other from
across the locker room but we were like
oh oh like we caught a piece together
what happened you can't think about it
was my first role that was my first role
that's like 10 Miller who was like a
gearhead kind of guy who did a lot of
drugs and was probably going to amount
very little in his life and in Michigan
it was the first time I really ever like
spoke on camera or acted or anything
like that I remember I'm very awkward
you can chart like my acting progression
as the show goes on for sure and I like
get much better as as it goes on and it
culminates in a pretty like strange but
great episode where I were with a girl
I'm dating tells me she was born a
hermaphrodite and it's dealt with like
very kind of touchingly and sincerely
which especially at the time was pretty
progressive I guess I mean it was yeah
or at least original I mean I was born
with both its most male and female parts
uh-huh
my parents made a decision with the
doctors that I should be a girl I mean
thank God because that's who I am
but it's still a really big part of my
life and I thought you should know no
this is good that yeah
you told me this I I had a great time
doing that Joan I still work with a lot
of those same people today I just saw
Martin Starr literally at my house
two days ago and so yeah we lived
together after that show so I was the
age of the geeks even though I was a
freak so I hung out with the geeks with
Jason Segel on also I became friends
with Franco nine years later actually
hanging on the show no we didn't hang
out during the show he I I wasn't sure
about him and he I yeah it wasn't it
wasn't until honestly like seven or
eight years later that we kind of became
friends again yeah what was working with
Judd Apatow like then back then it was
interesting I mean he was young and he
worked really hard and he was very
passionate about it he was not always
the most sensitive with the actors I
remember and undeclared he would boo us
Oscar
off camera huh if you didn't like what
we were doing he was here from the other
room boo and we're thinking like that's
baby dot the best way to be approaching
actors and direction but you know what I
was 18 so I just took it
[Music]
me and Evan Goldberg my writing partner
had a lot of like very strange ideas
that kind of went on to become movies
like this is the end it sausage party
you'd bite Apple Express but at the time
judge was like we just need to do
something simple like something that is
just like relatable and just like you
get instantly and I almost think like
conversationally one day he was like we
should make a movie about you like
getting a girl pregnant and that was
kind of it and I was a little nervous
about being a leading man
I was pretty cocky when I was younger
though so no III look back and marvel at
how little self-doubt I had in
comparison to now which I'm just I'm
just and I we incorporated a lot from my
real life into that like well first of
all all my actual friends played my
actual friends and roommates and I had
lived with I think half the people who
played my roommates in the movie at one
point or another was Jonah Hill and
Jason Segel and Martin Starr and Jay
Baruchel and then the way we lived the
furniture a lot of that [ __ ] literally
the couch was Evan Goldberg couch the
coffee table was his coffee table in my
apartment in the movies they were my
paintings that I literally painted the
judge took and put on the walls of my
apartment in the movie she really didn't
seem to like me like she wasn't laughing
at my jokes I'm like a funny guy [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] nothing it was a lot from our real
life there's a story there's a joke
where Martin is having a competition to
see how long you go without shaving but
all right listen you don't shave your
beard or cut your hair for one year and
if you can do that I will pay your rent
but if you shave then you have to pay
all five of our rents thanks for the
free money [ __ ] that was the thing that
we would do with our friends that movie
I mean a lot of our movies are inspired
by our real lives with that one took a
lot from what we were going through like
at that moment and put it right into the
movie me and katherine heigl got along
really well while we were making the
movie well I thought she was hilarious
and and we seemed
a good dynamic you should just support
me you know you should just support
everything I say because this juncture
in my life I'm allowed to be wrong so if
you're wrong I have to support it I can
tell you that you're like a lunatic oh
no oh that's helpful you have to do
nothing my job my body my youth my
vagina really life a lot of the movie is
us fighting and yelling at each other
and she really was a good a good fighter
and it made for pineapple express
[Music]
originally again when we wrote Pineapple
Express I was supposed to place in our
heads I was gonna place all the drug
dealer and we would get like a more
conventional leading man to play daya
like Franco and then we started to think
like maybe that's like a little expected
and then our mara we met with Franco
about it for the first time and he was
like I kind of want to play the other
guy we were like you know what like that
is probably more interesting it gives me
a chance to have a bigger role which is
fantastic and it gave him a chance to do
something like totally unexpected
hands-down dopest dope I've ever smoked
is not better than the blue öyster
really can't be I don't handle this is
like if that blue öyster [ __ ] met that
Afghan Kush I had and they had a baby
and then meanwhile that crazy Northern
Lights stuff I had and the super red a
special snowflake met and had a baby and
by some miracle those two babies met and
thought this would be this [ __ ] the big
birds people thought we were really
crazy for making that movie at the time
I remember tell our friends what we were
working on we're like we're gonna like a
weed action comedy and at the time that
sounded just [ __ ] stupid like well I
remember people just be like that sounds
stupid we were like yeah we're trying to
make like we're not stupid person we're
looking our heads just us I think I
think it could work and yeah this idea
of kind of combining I mean we were huge
like pulp fiction fans so like we really
liked the idea of combining kind of like
violence and life-and-death stakes it's
very violent yeah
which at the time in a comedy also was
like not cool and like not something
that a lot of people were like expecting
to work and and and it was not like on
the best received movie when it came out
like it did well like people liked it
and it's still the movie of this day
that if like people by far come up to me
the most and tell them that that's my
favorite that's their favorite movie of
mine at the time like yeah it was you
know it did well but it was not viewed
as like a great step to do in a bold new
direction for us I think but I viewed it
as that I'm very proud of that movie I
think that movies it's just crazy
David Gordon Green directed that which
was a surprising choice at the time
another thing is at the time there was
not a lot of like comedies that we were
fans of like it was a time when comedies
were like super silly and broad and kind
of just we weren't that psyched about
what was going on out there and so we
were like we should look in new
directions for directors like and
instead of hiring the people who do
these like big like wedding crashers
let's hire someone who does like
independent movies with like emotional
stories that we really like because we
really knew that was like the most
important thing was like the emotional
stories and and that the movies be like
a little deeper and a little more
resonant than you expect them to be that
was kind of always like the face we had
up our sleeves we thought we're it's
like yeah it's cool if it's a weed
action movie but if you actually find
yourself like caring about the
characters characters and what's
happening to them and their relationship
with each other than like that would be
something that no one would expect to
happen you know and and David Gordon
Green I remember our friends I remember
he we heat like all the real girls and
George Washington were just movies also
like if you were in film school you were
like [ __ ] obsessed with
and he went to film school with Jody
Hill and Danny Danny McBride in those
guys and and they had made the foot fist
way which was a movie we were huge fans
of and we were just like oh these guys
and we watched some of David's early
short films which are batshit [ __ ]
crazy but very funny
and when you meet David he's very funny
and so we met him and we were like yeah
I look back and think how like quickly
we made that decision at how little like
scrutiny we put it through and it shocks
me to this day like I watched George
Washington and all the real girls I met
him once for 45 minutes and we were like
cool let's do it
it's an awkward time in comedy we were
like younger than a lot of the guys were
acting it was the time when like Vince
Vaughn Owen Wilson been storing those
guys really famous so like like when it
came to looking for guys in their 20s to
star in comedies yeah like what you had
to fight you really had to look for new
and new directions and we thought Franco
was funny but he'd been doing these
really serious movies and we were like
oh like he's funny like I knew he would
commit so hard which he did and like
what I was surprised by was how like
funny we were together which was nice
like I wasn't a hundred percent sure of
that no no a woman policewoman every guy
another guy shot another guy an Asian
guy in the window [ __ ] Ted's house
I don't know he's a big gray-haired man
in Euro but he [ __ ] shot him in brain
we very quickly fell into like a rhythm
where I think we could both feel it was
like a good dynamic the foot suck in the
windshield joke is still one of like of
all the jokes we've come up with is one
of my favorite jokes we've come up with
we like it when especially like action
plays off of your expectation and
there's nothing more fun than when an
audience thinks they know what's gonna
happen and then they couldn't be more
sure and then something different
happens and with that joke I mean it
just and it also like informs character
like clearly like these guys watch a lot
of movies in a movie of your windshield
shattered what do you do they always
kick it out and the audience knows that
as well they watch a lot of movies so
they couldn't be more sure what's going
to happen cuz only one thing has ever
happened in that scenario and I remember
we thought oh man what would probably
happen is your foot would just go right
through the [ __ ] window and then
you're stuck driving with your foot
through a window and yeah and it was I
think honestly to this day it is
probably in a movie theater the biggest
laugh in any of our movies like I
remember seeing like I go to all the
screenings and we see the movies when
they're in the theaters and like I think
that moment like nothing compares to
that moment there's lines and pineapple
express about how he wants weed to be
legalized in the next five years or he's
lost all faith in humanity that was in
2008 I guess so 2013 was maybe five
years after that so a little late yeah
Canada has federally legalized cannabis
which is fantastic and I think a real
step in a very progressive direction and
I am one of the owners and founders of a
cannabis company called house plant
which is currently only available in
Canada and one of the reasons for that
is because America it although certain
states have legal weed it's still
federally illegal which causes huge
problems for tons of people and and I
think although America's like inching in
the right direction until they federally
legalize it and give amnesty to the
people who have been you know charged
with you know reasonable nonviolent
crimes during the prohibition of
cannabis and like that's what we need to
reach towards I think
this is the end
you know why it was weird it was weird
playing Seth Rogen kind of but it was
very freeing in some ways what was nice
is like again like playing off of
audience expectation is something we
talk a lot about as we write our movies
and like what was so nice was making a
movie where you kind of knew what
everyone was expecting of every
character going into it and we don't
have to like there was a version
actually cuz the studio [ __ ] hated
the idea of us playing ourselves and we
just straight-up lied to them and they
were like you have to film a version of
the movie where you could maybe cut
around the fact that they play
themselves and we were like sure no
problem and then we just [ __ ] I
remember showing up the senator just
said Seth Rogen painted a huge like the
painting on the wall and it was just
like well this is gonna be harder than I
thought and then we actually started
writing a version of the script where we
don't play ourselves and it instantly
was just like what the [ __ ] are we then
like it took so much out of the fun of
the movie and so we just left it and
lied to the studio and thank god it
worked but yeah it was fun because yeah
like I think people have this
expectation of all of us and of media
being was kind of like nice shrubby guy
who's trying to make everyone happy and
be liked you know and and that was
became the basis for the entire
character and the other thing is like it
really played into a lot of very real
dynamics like me and Jay like we're very
close and we kind of grew apart
once I you know as the years went on and
he did move back to Canada and I stay in
LA and he did start coming here and not
telling me and I would find out about it
through our other mutual friends and and
at the same time it was things like him
and like in the movie heaven Jonah like
he is mad at Jonah even though Jonah's
trying to be nice to him all the time
which is like kind of a thing that would
happen
[Music]
Pete is tight weed is tight that's
awesome it's like the golfing sequence
of Navy SEALs
reference though oh thanks but if your
references are out of control everyone
knows that
hey thanks ramp it was pretty like it
was probably more as informed by real
life than even people think it is for a
movie where we all play ourselves like a
cop I remembered we sent Jay the first
draft did he called this back it was
like whoa like you guys really went
there I were like yeah we we went all
the way there
did you drop that yeah me and Evan drove
was that your first the foamy direct
yeah it was the first movie
what was that experience like it was uh
it was fun honestly like it's a
technically very complicated movie
there's a lot of visual effects and big
like set pieces I hate it in there I
just want to drink some pop
that element of it was was complicated
but ultimately you fulfilling honestly
the reason we directed it is because we
were like no none of these people will
do this if if we're not directing it
like we couldn't hire someone else to do
it we thought there was no one they were
trust enough to kind of hand themselves
over in this way and because I was
participating it as in it as well like
it broke down a lot of those barriers
too I think with the actors because they
were like well he's doing it so I should
at least try and if it doesn't work well
I'll tell him to [ __ ] take it out um
but yeah that was really why we directed
it as we were like we have to they just
won't do this for anybody else Mindy
Kaling's in the movie I think she falls
in the hole and Rihanna's in the movie
and she falls in a hole Paul Rudd's in
the movie he crushes the lady's head and
then runs away holding a big bottle of
champagne which is one of my favorite
jokes in the movie
Jason Siegel's in the movie he falls in
the hole Kevin Hart Michael Cera dies
very early on pretty in a pretty grim
way becomes a king and has a sexual I
call him Channing Tatum for a half
throughout almost the entire filming the
movie we were like we'll never get a
famous person to do this so we shouldn't
even ask someone and then one day Jonah
was like I thought Channing Tatum would
do it and I emailed him saying like I'm
not gonna sugarcoat this it is not a
forgiving role you will have to be on
your heads at these for two days
straight basically um and you will play
Danny McBride like sexual jimp plaything
and within 30 seconds I got an email
back that was just like yes I'm in wait
tell me where and where I'll do it
and God bless him he did the interview
yeah every interview came from I mean I
feel like it's almost like this idea
that's out there in the ether is like
these famous journalists kind of have
access to like at times some of the most
dangerous people in the world in a way
that no military or government could
have access interview this guy he's the
most reclusive leader on the planet it's
not gonna happen he lives in North Korea
we can't go there
Dave Skylark gets in anywhere do you
remember that Club three-month waiting
list hmm first night I don't think it's
quite the same thing
well there were a lot of Asian girls
there and I think a lot of people make
the joke of like oh why don't they kill
that person and at the same time you
know we were super fascinated by North
Korea and we started to think this idea
of like you know Kim jong-un like
inviting kind of like a dumb egocentric
American to North Korea and kind of
painting this picture of how wonderful
it is and and tricking him into kind of
expounding the glories of North Korea
onto the world was a funny idea and then
it happened in real life with the
President of the United States so
fuckin'-a was improvised probably what
is there to be jealous of [ __ ] his
heinous cuz they anus they hate us cuz
we anus the [ __ ] doesn't eNOS have to do
hate us because they ain't us that's not
what it is yes it is no it's not they
hate us cuz we is us and what we is
doing is [ __ ] terrible they [ __ ]
hate us because they love saying that
[Music]
stop it don't say it again seems like
something me and Franco would have just
started screaming at each other but yeah
that that of all the things in that
movie that line is really hung on can
you tell me about shoving the missile up
your butt yeah there's a scene where I
shove a missile up my butt and that was
actually because there's like a tracking
device in it I know I'm gonna find it
and then
there are people there they are closing
in on you
they have guns you need to secure the
payload and you need to secure it in
your ass to the soothing tones of my
voice just breathe the tip is it's the
worst part trust me on this then there's
a part where they take me and they
strip-searched me and they have dogs
like trying to sniff it out and arguably
the worst thing I've done but I was the
director at the movie also so I had no
one to blame or yell at but myself we
needed the dog to kind of stick to sniff
my ass basically and it wouldn't so I
essentially had to shove like turkey
jerky up my ass to get the dog to like
snake the stick its nose in my ass and I
remember there was a guy from like like
but you main society there cuz when
you're were edibles on set like they're
there and I remember turning to him
being like is this okay he was like the
dog doesn't mind I'm amazed you're
subjecting yourself to this but the dog
doesn't [ __ ] care like this is not
abusive to the dog but you should really
second-guess every choice you've made
that's led you to this moment in that
scene you open up and you shake your I
shake my private parts around ya how did
you Foley that sound effect it's so
realistic it's a dog wagging its head
and its tongue flopping around
it's all yours [ __ ] stay in the room
American catch up I remember we actually
asked the Foley people what they still
Foley movies which is insane like it's
the [ __ ] 1913 and they yes that sound
is a dog like wagging its face
throughout that it's like tongue and
lips slapping against its own head it's
funny that I know the answer to that
question
observe and report I play a guy named
Ronnie Barnhardt who is like bipolar guy
he who kind of views himself he kind of
has like he's like ego he's kind of very
egocentric and a narcissist but also
very deeply depressed I'm here with
Ronnie Barnhardt one of the security
guards here at the mall you [ __ ] up
ma'am I'm the head of mall security used
to do that again and say it right well
officer Barnhardt right is there any
information you can shed on this
situation he's gonna keep going and he
[ __ ] up my title
he's a mall security guard and he makes
it his mission to catch a flasher he
does catch that man and he shoots him
the whole end of the movie is me like
chasing a naked man through a mall in
slow motion and it's like pretty
remarkable
[Music]
I remember as we were filming it on my I
was like crazy
[Music]
and the movie paul blart mall cop came
out like a few ones before and kind of
[ __ ] us
we heard rumblings about paul Blart and
then we like yeah and then years later I
heard that they actually like got the
script and ripped us off even though
they're very different movies paul blart
made I think six times the amount of
money of observer report though one way
or another I'm not thrilled with paul
blart mall cop in relation to how
observer report was received Steve Jobs
was we're playing a real person and it
was even weirder that that person was
Steve Wozniak I don't think there's a
man who's done more to advance the
democratization that comes with personal
computing that I have but you've never
had any respect for me now why is that
I've at least consider the possibility
that's because you've never had any for
me I luckily got to spend a lot of time
with him we became pretty close I still
email him every now and then yeah I went
out to dinner with him a few times and
spent a lot of time with him and he's a
pretty like eccentric dude who has a lot
of very specific manner in there we're
talking to Danny Boy a lot about that I
was like how much of this stuff do you
want me to do and he was like some of it
the one of the best things I was I went
to the Magic Castle which with Steve
Wozniak and his wife and my wife which
was a crazy experience cuz magicians
aren't nerds and if you're also if
you're a nerd there are a few people
cooler than [ __ ] Steve Wozniak and
like it was like walking in with like
you know [ __ ] David Copperfield or
something like that and the funniest
part is at the end of the night he he
had a segue that him and his wife came
to the Magic Castle on segways which
they had parked in the parking lot just
leaned against a wall and I was like
these must be I was like I think you got
on the Segway bandwagon pretty early
he's like these are the first two
segways like they're serial numbers one
and two and he's like but the funny
thing about that is they don't have
headlights but it was at night so he
reached through a bag and pulled out two
flashlights and gave one to him and what
him to his wife and I literally just saw
him Segway away down Hollywood Boulevard
like holding flashlights in one hand and
sig Willian with the other and I was
like that guy invented personal
computers
long shot long shot I play a journalist
named Fred filarsky who was very
opinionated and idealistic to his own
fault and he's very politically minded
or so he thinks and he was babysat by a
woman who's become the secretary of
state and who's running for president
and she hires him as a speechwriter and
he very quickly learns a lot about
himself and reconnects with who he used
to be
[Music]